Welcome back.
Actually, before I teach you how
to figure out how high the
ball went-- and you might
already be able to figure it
out-- I want to show you
really kind of a more
intuitive way for figuring out
how fast the ball went.
I used the equation this first
time, just to really show you
that this equation can be
useful, but I personally
always forget equations, so I
find it very useful to have
kind of a common sense way of
figuring it out, as well.
And really, this equation was
derived by coming up with a
common sense way-- I don't know
if that last statement
made sense, but let's move on.
Let's say that same problem, but
let's just think about it
without our equations, because
that's always a good fall back
when you're panicking in the
middle of the exam, and you
can't remember if an equation
had a 1/2, or a 2, or a minus,
or a plus, or t, or t squared.
It's good just to think about
what's happening.
So when I throw a ball straight
up-- I have a, let's
say it's a baseball, it looks
like a baseball-- and I throw
it straight up where my velocity
initial is equal to--
well, let's say that
this the variable.
This is my initial velocity,
v sub i.
What's going to happen?
As soon as I throw it up,
it's going to start
decellerating, right?
Because I have the force of
gravity decelerating it
immediately-- so, with gravity,
we're saying minus 10
meters per second
squared, right?
This ball is going to keep
decelerating until its
velocity goes to 0, right?
The ball, if we were to graph
time and distance, where this
is time, and then this
is distance.
Right?
At time zero, we're
on the ground.
The ball starts off going
really fast, then starts
slowing down, then its velocity
goes to 0, and then
it starts accelerating in the
negative direction, and it
starts going fast, and bam--
it hits the ground again.
What happens is that the ball
starts fast, and starts going
slower, slower, slower, slower,
and slower, until its
velocity is 0, and then it
starts-- you could say
reaccelerating in the opposite
direction-- or decellerating,
really-- but reaccelerating in
the opposite direction, and
then it hits the ground.
Actually, we know-- assuming
nothing about air resistance,
et cetera et cetera-- that the
velocity that it hits the
ground with is the same velocity
that it left your
hand with, just in the
opposite direction.
So there's a couple of
interesting things here.
The time at which its velocity
is at 0-- so that point right
there-- that's going to
be at t equals 2.
We know that this shape is
actually a parabola, if you
remember that from
algebra two.
Why is that a parabola?
What was the equation for it?
We figured out the equation
using that previous formula.
I don't want to use it this
time, but what was that
previous formula?
It was change in distance
is equal to vit plus at
squared over 2.
It's a parabola, but I think if
you had thought about it,
you would have realized
also it's a parabola.
And it points downward because
a is negative, so the t
squared term is negative--
that's why it opens to the
downward side.
I think that might make
a little sense to you.
So what we could figure out
is, if we're given a t, we
could say well, half of that
number-- let's say that t
equals 10 seconds.
So we know that in 10 seconds,
the ball left my hand, went up
some distance, and then came
back down and hit the ground.
What we also know then, though,
is that t over 2 at 5
seconds, the ball was
essentially stationary for
just a moment-- its velocity had
decelerated, decelerated,
decelerated, and hit 0, and then
right before it started
reaccelerating again, or
reaccelerating downwards, its
velocity was 0 at the
time t equals 0.
The fact that the ball
decelerated from my initial
velocity to 0 in 5 seconds--
what does that tell us?
Well, we have the very simple
equation, you know, change in
velocity is equal to
acceleration times time, right?
You probably knew that before
watching any of these videos.
And the change in the
acceleration, well, that's
just the final velocity minus
the initial velocity is equal
to the acceleration
times time.
In this situation, what's
the final velocity?
Remember, we're not going to
go all the way here-- we're
just figuring out from here
to time equals 2, right?
So what's the final velocity?
We're saying that point is where
the ball is not going
up, and it's not going down,
so its final velocity is 0.
So, 0 minus initial velocity
is equal to acceleration--
acceleration is the acceleration
of gravity--
minus 10 meters per
second squared.
I know it's a little confusing,
because I'm using
the same t, but let's say that
this time is t sub 0, just to
kind of make sure it's not a
variable, it's actual time.
So this is t sub naught
over 2, right?
Because the ball is motionless
right at the peak of its--
we're not an arc, but right
at the peak of its travel.
So, it's acceleration times
time, but at this time, the
time is going to be t
sub naught over 2.
Once again, the 0 doesn't
matter, and we can multiply
both sides times negative 1.
We get plus vi, and we get vi is
equal to 10 divided by 2--
5 meters per second squared
t sub naught.
Which was exactly what we got in
the previous video when we
used this formula.
And I think it makes sense to
you -- hopefully, this was
kind of an intuitive way of
thinking about what happened.
Before actually I do the
distance, I actually want to
graph what's happening, because
I think it just dawned
on me that that might be
something that will give you
more intuition.
I'm all about giving you
intuition so you never forget
this stuff.
So this is, if we were to
graph-- that's an ugly looking
axes, but I think you'll get the
point-- this is distance,
this is time.
We already said it's going to be
like a parabola, like that.
Right?
Where this is t sub naught over
2, this t sub naught.
It launches really fast, then
it slows down, and then it's
motionless right here,
and then it starts
reaccelerating downwards.
If that's the distance,
what does the
velocity graph look like?
The velocity graph, I'll draw
right below-- I'll draw it in
another color, just
for variety.
That's a bold.
So over-- actually, that's not
how I want to draw it.
I have to draw the negative
side, too.
So this is time, and then this
axis is velocity, so we start
off at a positive
velocity, right?
We start off at v sub i, and
what's going to happen here is
the velocity decreases at
a constant rate, right?
And that rate is just the
rate of acceleration.
The velocity decreases until
at t sub naught-- let me
switch back to yellow-- at t sub
naught-- woops, I'm using
the wrong tool, it actually
looked like I was drawing
something-- at t sub naught,
the velocity now is
negative vi, right?
Remember we said, when the ball
comes back down, it's
going at the same velocity,
just at
the opposite direction.
This point right here, which is
t sub naught over 2, that
corresponds to this
point, right?
Which makes sense, because
that's the point at which the
ball has no velocity.
And look, the velocity is 0.
So the ball starts going up
really fast, slows down at a
constant rate, and what is
the slope of this line?
Well, the slope is just the
acceleration, right?
Because velocity is the
acceleration times time.
And then it's stationary for
just a moment, because its
velocity is 0, and then it
starts accelerating-- or you
could say decelerating, or
accelerating in the negative
direction-- until the
point that it's
going at v sub i down.
And of course, if you were to
graph acceleration-- if I were
to graph acceleration
over time--
acceleration is constant.
It's right here.
Let me just get a line tool.
Acceleration is just a constant
minus 10 meters per
second, so it's going
to look like that.
And it's just the slope
of this line.
If you know calculus, it'll make
sense to you that this
line is the derivative of this
line, or this curve.
This line is the derivative
of this curve.
And even if you don't know
calculus, I think it makes
sense to you that this is
the slope of this line.
And just so, if you haven't
learned calculus, a derivative
is just to a way of figuring out
a slope at any point along
the curve, so it's nothing
too fancy.
I'll see you in the
next presentation.